Homestar Runner captivated the pre-YouTube
internet with its offbeat characters, its
simple cartooning, and its...
Strong Bad.
Who are the brothers who created these absurdly
entertaining personas?
How did the show evolve over time?
What was the key to its success?
Homestar Runner started out as a kids book.
Created by brothers Matt and Mike Chapman
and their filmmaker friend Craig Zobel during
the Summer Olympics in 1996, the book was
called The Homestar Runner Enters the Strongest
Man in the World Contest.
It introduced static versions of such beloved
characters as Homestar Runner, Pom Pom, and
the Cheat.
Strong Bad was there too, playing a straight-up
villain in his premiere role.
"Ohhh, these grapes are succulently crushing
my windpipe."
After taking a couple of hours to craft the
characters, they finished the book in a single
day, showing both a flair for speedy production
and the trademark offbeat comedy that would
come to define the site.
They printed a few copies for their friends,
and eventually made a short animation based
on Homestar using Mario Paint.
"Look out!
It's strong bad!"
A few years after the book, the Chapman brothers,
also known as "The Brothers Chaps," began
to think about the possibilities.
The pair believed in the potential so much
that Mike actually dropped out of grad school
in order to start teaching himself how to
animate in Flash.
"Whoa man these graphics are state of the
art graphics."
But, of course, in order to produce a video,
they needed something to put in it, and they
decided to go back to their old children's
book for inspiration.
Thus it came about that Homestar Runner found
its way off the page and onto the screen.
The cartooning of the book was simple, and
it proved the perfect subject to use for animation
practice.
The website launched in 2000, initially serving
simply as a place to house some of the videos
they were creating.
One of the oddest things about Homestar Runner
is the name itself.
With no obvious connection to anything collectively
recognizable, where exactly did this peculiar
name come from?
Believe it or not, it originated from an inside
joke that came about when a group of kids
innocently made fun of a bad commercial.
Mike Chapman explained that the name found
its origin when one day the brothers were
hanging out with their friend James Huggins,
who went on to become a member of the band
Of Montreal.
"Tell them his other significance real quick.”
"He was the one that coined the phrase ‘Homestar
Runner.’”
When James was trying to make fun of a commercial
that starred Mark Lemke of the Atlanta Braves,
he tried to use terminology that was simply
out of his experience, blurting out something
along the lines of "Homestar runner for the
Braves Mike Lemke!"
The name obviously stuck in the minds of the
Brothers Chaps, and they tucked it away for
later use.
One bothersome question that has always stood
front and center with Homestar Runner is the
lead character's puzzling lack of arms.
Most of the other characters surrounding Homestar
have arms, even if many of them are missing
hands or perpetually wearing boxing gloves.
But while the lack of arms has never slowed
Homestar Runner down, the question still stands
- why?
The answer, in this case, is right in the
name itself.
As Mike Chapman pointed out, Homestar was
created to be an excellent athlete - not just
an athlete, but a runner in particular.
Since he was designed to run, why would he
need arms?
Strong Bad, Strong Mad, and Strong Sad make
up the Strong Brothers Three, with the trio
showing up in numerous videos and always causing
some kind of havoc and humor.
But while the characters have their own extremely
unique qualities within the Homestar Runner-verse,
they aren't actually made up from scratch.
It turns out that the entire idea of the "Strong
Clan" is actually borrowed from a team of
wrestlers that appeared on the '80s NES game
Tag Team Wrestling.
The game follows two different wrestling tag-teams,
the Ricky Fighters and the Strong Bads, with
one of the latter wearing a red Luchador mask
that is clearly the inspiration for the beloved
Homestar character.
It was just a matter of time before the ever-depressing
Strong Sad and the childishly angry Strong
Mad arrived on the scene, and the whole Strong
brotherhood was officially born into existence.
"Finally my comeuppance has arrived."
For a while, the Homestar Runner website clicked
along steadily with a small audience, but
eventually, the Chapmans realized they were
making it big - all thanks to Strong Bad's
emails.
The endless procession of shorts that showcased
Strong Bad answering bizarre emails with sometimes
nonsensical answers proved to be the pivotal
turning point that turned Homestar Runner
into an internet sensation.
The best part about the Strong Bad emails,
though, is that they were genuine emails from
real fans.
"Yours truly, Johnny well on.
Oh, I left my Johnny well on.
Johnny Well… off."
While the Chapman brothers have been at the
heart of all things Homestar Runner over the
years, they probably never could have pulled
off what they did without a little bit of
help.
This came, in particular, from their parents,
who were supportive of their endeavors right
from the get-go.
Their parents also allowed the brothers to
fill their home with the burgeoning business
as things like production and fulfillment
of merch orders steadily claimed more and
more room throughout the house.
Their father worked alongside his sons to
serve as their accountant and to help them
manage the copyrights for their characters.
He was even a driving force behind convincing
Matt to quit his job in 2003 in order to pursue
Homestar full-time.
While many parents have supported their children's
dreams over the years, there's little doubt
that the Chapmans' folks were more supportive
than most.
When you hear of a site that's getting hundreds
of thousands of visitors, it's only natural
to wonder how the webmasters have monetized
that traffic.
But, while the Chapman brothers did, indeed,
make a living off of Homestar Runner for the
decade or so that its star was on the rise,
the success was shockingly stripped of any
of the ads that typically help bring in the
cash.
How did they make their money?
With merch.
At times they literally had fans clamoring
for shirts, hoodies, and other merchandise
emblazoned with their favorite online heroes.
It was the sale of Homestar Runner products
that kept that the site alive for years.
Of course, you can't mention Strong Bad and
his email success without a shout-out to his
favorite '80s band, "Limozeen."
Not only did the band appear in shorts like
the one about crayon color names, but it actually
manifested in a coloring book that you can
still download and print off for free.
That's right, Homestar Runner wasn't just
on the forefront of '80s nostalgia and internet
animation, it also helped pioneer the adult
coloring book genre!
The band's history goes even further than
that, though.
Remember how the Chapmans' friend James Huggins,
accidental creator of the name Homestar Runner,
ended up in the band Of Montreal?
It turns out that Strong Bad's favorite band
actually opened for them, as well.
In 2008, the band played at the Tabernacle
in Atlanta, Georgia.
Ten years after opening the site, the brothers
decided a hiatus was in order.
But that didn't mean that Homestar and company
were being entirely left in the rear-view
mirror.
A few years later, they began producing occasional
shorts in order to give their die-hard fans
some fresh material.
But the Brothers Chaps had spent too much
time in the limelight to quietly disappear
into a "normal" life.
Instead, they managed to leverage their popularity
as the creators of a cultural phenomenon into
very decent jobs working on shows like Yo
Gabba Gabba! on Nickelodeon and Gravity Falls
and Two More Eggs for Disney.
While we still do get the occasional fresh
piece of content, it seems that the days of
weekly Strong Bad emails, the ongoing adventures
of Dangeresque, and Trogdor burninating new
countrysides may be officially part of the
past.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.